baissant de l'été qui bille en tête et
que le questionnaire un pédéraste
notoire répète projet
première question par celle de son
prénom rouste besoin qui est pour toi le
comble la misère
pour
de passer inaperçu moi j'aurais dit
absence de papier cul c'est moi qui fais
le test de seconde question le problème
là tu vivre parce que parce que j'y ai
passé une semaine génial et que je me
dis comme parce que je me suis fait
chier je me dis qu'à la saga ça serait
bien tu peux officier à metz un piège
les jambes ai pas beaucoup je savais pas
trop de thunes mais c'était marrant dieu
quoi batista pas de thunes tu leur dis
pas ce que je dis c'est pas grave je
n'ai pas perdu beaucoup de couches
minces à l'accord dont l'idéal de
bonheur que rage
je dois pas en avoir puisque je m'en
mets en partout mais avec du fric en
fait sous même pas être obligés de
travailler qua non pour tabac tue alors
battu thomas qu'avec la wii mais ceux
avec qui je me maquille jamais de blé
alors
demain mais les bleus s'ils sont pas
forcément d'un coup pour quelle faute
tueur plus d'indulgence
on habite ici
elle m'a tellement je suis en vie
jennifer moi je réduis est fou de leur
tour
quels sont les héros de romans que tu
pourrais faire c'est difficile j'ai
jamais rien n a vraiment mis en marche
alors qu'il est très près presque n'ont
jamais pas des romans et 000 points de
vue et à l'infini ton patron favoris
numéro de francis bacon que la qualité
préféré je suis l'homme
qui veut ça gueule comme des nombreux
personnellement que ça m'intéressait pas
je sais pas j'aime pas trop les samares
je m'en fous de la qualité et du feu et
d'égalité vote
qu'est ce que tu as en toi je suis en
tirs des mortiers
je vis là pour manger pour vous les yeux
vis la magie tels que des yeux mais
c'est tout le temps les occupations
préférées fut facile parce que ça j'en
ai pas d occupation profonde qu'est ce
que tu as eu le succès du roi dont je
vous emmerde souvent en r je sais pas
manger la sauce foyer maintenant ça va
ça qui aurait tué m tu n'étais pas
béatrice dalle
c'est pas que je suis contente d'être
mois mais personne d'autre non plus bas
donc principal défaut
mais
qui peut
je suis jalouse jalouse c'est quoi est
pas des choses si hassen défaut parce
que ça me prend la tête à moi aussi
aussi mais ça la limite c'est moins
grave mais ça me prend la tête à moins
que youtube
les urnes remplies quel serait ton plus
grand malheur
être obligé d'avoir un travail tous les
jours
frappe rase ou à la couleur que tu
préfères
vers bébé j'aime bien vers buvait y est
le reflet elle aurait dit kaka doigt
parce que ça sonne eu le don de la
nature que tu aimerais avoir
moi je suis très bien comme ça alors
finalement ça va quoi jouer de la
musique wet scinde en la matière ça
oisifs et ben moi c'est faire caca
sarzeau de passer classe comment
aimerais tu mourir jument pas mourir ça
va la terre je ne sais pas je me suis
pas posé la question j'ai pas du tout
aucun plaisir à mourir moi je l'aimerais
mourir religion the last one
quel est l'état préemptons esprit
présent j'ai pas mes présences au chrono
présent
j'ai pas ça va bien ça